what do you like most about how you look
vain
I like just this mask its menacing
that's fantastic and it just makes me
sound awesome
have you been scaring people at
comic-con here today
I've been scaring quite a few people a
lot of people have been very intimidated
by just my sheer presence does that make
you feel good it makes me feel very good
it makes me want to scare people more I
think it's just that sort of
anticipation but the power of dominance
I think is fantastic when you walk
through the comic-con here through the
various aisles do they kind of part like
the Moses and the Red Sea's when you
walk through because Bane is coming and
he's a badass they do and they chant as
well which is fantastic there's a line
there you shake their fists up in the
air and they're not our on leader has
come it's fantastic this is like a huge
power trip for you something like this
this is a huge power trip for me anyone
that we can lead over to the dark side
is fantastic
you